I love when girls put their hair up they
do that what are they doing back there
I think it's super sexy though when
girls have the messy hair it's kind of
like you just went to the gym but you
can still go to prom with him like that
regular eyebrows on girls hair that's
like push to the side like when it's all
sort of like to one side freckles I
don't think that your lips did enough
credit a small of a woman's back like
the line down a woman's back is one of
the sexiest things in the world I could
just see her back and just like this Oh
women's backs in general I don't know
it's it's a thing you know what I don't
like people I really appreciate when a
girl is pretty feet like I'm not a fan
of feet so when a girl has really pretty
feet I'm like wow you have great feet I
like chicks who have their own sense of
style I don't want you to look like a
mannequin from any store I want you to
be your own mannequin going to or coming
from yoga is always a plus I really like
big sweaters high-waisted shorts I love
those I like boots too I mean I'm a
southern boy I like simple things I
don't get too weird with it I like
chapstick a lot more than lipstick
there's a super classy or like sexually
confident I don't care what people see
and when they see it it's mine and they
can't have it girls in New York would
wear like their rain boots like Curious
George rain boots I just think it's
funny like they're gonna be romping
around in a puddle she's in a sundress
and it's beautiful yeah she's probably
not wearing anything else underneath the
sundress that's in my world it's
flirtation in a piece of cloth when one
is comfortable with with weird things
that she she likes that she knows we're
weird I love a girl that can give me a
hard time I love a girl who has like
witty comebacks and they love it when
women give me a hard time I genuine
thoughtfulness without other people is
really attractive Oh like that's the
perfect like 36-24-36
honestly it really is about how you rock
if a girl can sing that's like [ __ ]
it for me driven ambitious really
intelligent I need a girl who's equally
as driven as me I love miss independent
cuz she got home I don't need her
waiting for me to make things work
there's too much to be done
there's probably ten years ago now I
went on a cruise met this girl beautiful
Harriet songs I have a scene sexiest
Harriet songs that have a scene there
Harriet in mind but that's cool though
it worked for her